you
all right hi everyone looks like I'm
live welcome to this free code camp live
stream on view Jas I'm so excited that
they're letting me live stream from this
platform if you don't know me my name is
Gwen and I live stream on my own channel
which is Faraday Academy which is in the
description below so for this series
what I'm going to be doing on Fridays on
free code camp is build the front-end
free code camp projects in view Jas and
it's gonna start with the random quote
machine you can see that I made this
repo here free code camp - projects dot
view I'm actually gonna post this in the
chat so you have a link to it I
basically only did some readme files and
stuff so far all right there you go
if anyone wants a link and so in each in
this repo I'm gonna make a folder for
each project as I go along and today
like I said before will be this random
quote machine now what I'm gonna be
doing with View is actually starting off
with the most basic projects so I'm
gonna start off or the most basic view
so if you don't know what View Jas is
it's JavaScript framework and it's
called progressive because you can use
it as a very lightweight kind of jQuery
esque CDN import and just import it into
your HTML or you can you know generate a
whole big view project and use it more
as a full fledged framework so today I'm
just going to be importing it via CBN
into the HTML so yeah feel free to post
in the chat this chat is a little bit
different than the one I do on my
channel so I'll try to keep up and check
the chat every so many minutes and yeah
otherwise I'm just gonna go ahead and
get started coding so from the view J s
website I want to I'm going to click get
started so I can grab the CDN import
development version includes helpful
console warnings this is exactly what I
want and it's just one import the cool
thing about view is that there's you
don't have to use JSX or anything it
uses HTML by default so you don't need
to import babel or trance pile or do
anything else you can just import view
and start using it so i have my code on
this screen this is the same github repo
that i just showed you so just a few
files I do have some quotes already
ready for this there just Bob Ross
quotes and if you don't know Bob Ross
he's a famous TV painter back in the 80s
and 90s he was the most popular one in
the u.s. I think and then he has kind of
a cult following online now because of
his voice and the things he painted and
stuff like that anyway I really like him
and there are some quotes so now in my
quote machine folder I'm gonna create an
index dot HTML file let me zoom in a
little bit yeah let me know if you can
see that alright so now I am gonna just
create that as a regular HTML file so
HTML oh yeah
and let me just be totally correct and
set the doctype is is that correct I
don't know let me actually copy paste a
basic HTML oh they don't have one here
all right so I'm gonna leave this out
for now and just do HTML
and then set a head tag and then man
it's been so long since I made an HTML
file and then set a body tag okay and
okay and now I'm going to close my HTML
okay and now I'm gonna do set a title
and I'm gonna call this random quote
machine and so I'm using vyas code right
now and I think for next time I'm gonna
have a plug in or get an HTML plug-in
because I don't think I even have syntax
highlighting for HTML or maybe I'll just
go ahead and do that now
let me see HTML and CSS support okay
install and now it's available globally
I'm not sure if I have to reset to get
the features or maybe I just need to
reset the file let's hope that's the
case
okay so now I have a title so let me do
just a plain div here and close div and
now I'll just put hello inside all right
okay now let me open this in the browser
so what I'm gonna do is copy right-click
on the index.html file and I can say
copy path so I copied the path that's
the path to this file on my local
machine and then all I have to do is go
in my browser and paste that path and
now I see hello okay cool so now on my
oh yeah so I meant to show this first
but this is just the quote machine from
free code camp and then this is the demo
one and I'm gonna be creating something
really similar there's not a lot you can
do with a quote machine just you know a
random quote machine just a button that
gets a new quote basically okay
so let me get started so let me go into
my github repo if I look in the readme
for the quote machine I have this mock
up and this is what I want it to look
like so basically I have one card that's
gonna contain the quotes and then I have
a new quote button underneath so let's
see so first I need to create a card in
here and I'm gonna basically I'm going
to import bootstrap create the card and
the button and then I'm gonna hook it up
into view to show you how to do that so
first let me go to bootstrap this is
version 4.5 and then I'm gonna just get
the CSS import I'm not going to need
JavaScript the JavaScript import for
anything and now in my index.html file
in right below the title I'll just paste
that bootstrap CSS import okay so now I
have bootstrap and now I'm going to
search bootstrap for a card and
[Music]
this looks okay so basically you have a
class of card and then inside you have a
card body class and then you can put
title and text and stuff like that
alright so I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna get rid of hello and I'm
saving this div because this is gonna be
where I reference view from this outer
div so in this inner div I'm gonna do
let's say class equals card and then
oops div and then here inside I'll do
oops div and then class equals card body
and then one more div and I'll do div
class equals card text and that's where
the quotes are going to be inside so
I'll put a placeholder here and just say
this is quote and let me put quotes
around it okay that's fine let me see
what this looks like okay cool so I do
see that I don't know if you can see it
there's a gray line here and some
spacing it added so this is a quote or
this is a card but I want it just to be
centered on the page so I'm going to go
ahead and add bootstrap classes for that
and I'm going to add in here I'm going
to use their grid system so I'll do
another div and this one with a class of
let's see I think it's container but
let's see if it is so in bootstrap
I'm gonna look for grid
grid system and here I'm just gonna copy
this actually so I'm gonna copy this
bootstrap one so I can get to the view
part so let me all right
oops let me do div and close all these
divs div and is there one more that's
one more diff for the container I know
that's a lot of HTML nesting alright so
oh wait I messed up so I put one extra
div because I had started that before I
copy pasted these okay so I have
container row and column and here what
I'm gonna do is call them small and
let's say six and then I'm gonna do
column offset so let me search for
offset real quick offsetting columns so
it's offset and then the breakpoint so
like offset small of three is what I
want so let me do offset small of three
and see if that works okay that looks oh
I see what I did somehow I lost the card
in here so I have to recreate that card
div that's why there's no outline around
the card so I need a div of class card
indent this again and then close that
div okay and then I want to put some
margin on top of the card bootstrap
a bunch of spacing classes that are
abbreviated so for margin I can do
margin top of I think I can do five it
goes up to five maybe and that should be
something I can't remember how they
calculate it but it's something like 15
pixels or something okay so see now I
have my quote box that's good
and now below the box I need a button so
I'm gonna create that let's see where's
my card my cards here so I'm gonna
create it after the card so I'll do but
still inside the row in the column so
I'll do button and then I'll say new
quote and button all right so class
equals wait
I think it's BTN all right
so in the new bootstrap let me just
search for buttons because it might be a
different class now okay so it's BTN and
then BTN whatever I want so BTN let me
just do BTN primary okay so BTN primary
let's see if that works
cool awesome so now there's a button and
now there's a quote box so now on to
view and for view I think I or is it
here is the script tag that I want to
import view with so I'm gonna put that
at the bottom right above my closing
body tag and put the view script tag
okay so now I have you imported and
accessible in my project so now I need
to create another
view or a script here so I need to put
script create a script tag so I can
write my java script inside so i created
a script tag and now i need to declare a
new view instance so i basically have
access to this view variable right now
and so i can create a new view instance
by using the new keyword which is just a
javascript keyword which creates objects
so i can say new view and then i pass it
an object which is called the options
object so if you if you've heard about
view 2 and view 3 a lot of people are
thinking oh I don't want to learn view
yet because view 3 is coming out well
actually this same options object that
we're doing right now you're going to be
using the same API in view 3 there are
more advanced features and things that
you can use in view 3 but none of this
is going away so if you're thinking
about using view or learning view you
might as well start now because you can
use the same API even when they upgrade
the version let me just check the chat
real quick what application we're using
a balsamic balsamic mock-ups I've been
using them for I don't know maybe five
years it's just really easy to do
outlines this company so real quick they
have in online some kind of online one
but I have their desktop app and I
basically create easy wireframes in this
because it's so simple they give you a
bunch of like browsers and phones and
stuff and you can easily add text and
move things around so that's a great way
to do quick wireframes mock-ups that
kind of stuff ok so now I have a view
instance created
so now how do I use view while it needs
to attach to the Dom - I need to give it
an HTML element where it's gonna live so
view knows where to do its magic and
kind of so let's say element and let's
create an HTML element with the ID of
app this is pretty standard so this
empty div that I left on the outside I'm
actually going to give it an ID of app
so now view will be able to operate
anywhere inside of this div but not
outside like if I made divs below this
view wouldn't be able to know about them
because I told it only to look inside of
this app all right so you can do a lot
of things with view you can basically on
a most basic level you can make this
dynamic in view so I could do let's see
data and right now I'm using a data
object so what data means is basically
anything you put inside of here will be
available as variables inside of your
HTML where view is inside of your HTML
so I could put name is Gwen Gwen and
then so view uses this double curly
brace syntax it's called double mustache
syntax and now I can just put my
variable inside of here name okay so
something is wrong here so a good thing
I'm doing this so I can debug it first
so I'm referencing the element of ID app
and then I'm creating data and I have
named yeah so this should work let me
see
oh it is working it just took a second
to update all right let me refresh okay
good so there was no debugging needed
all right so yeah no problem okay so
cool so I was just showing you how to do
that so basically this hTML is connected
to our view instance so we can do lots
of cool things with events and and
variables and all kinds of stuff so
let's see what do we want to do next we
need to make these quotes dynamic and
then we need to make them random and
then we need to hook up this button to
actually generate a new quote every time
we click it so we're gonna have to
create some kind of function to work
when we click the button so for right
now though let's import the quotes and
try to display them so let me see I have
this quotes array so I think what I can
do is so I can't maybe I can just do
let's see let me create a variable here
so far quote equals this array and now
if I import this quote CAS file into my
HTML should be able to access that
variable so source equals quote CAS then
uh script alright ok so now I have I
should have access to quotes so let me
see if I can let me now try to put
quotes
on my or wait let me see if I have
access to quotes here so let me do
console dot log quotes and open my
console let me see
oh it's complaining about my HTML
document obviously my head head tag and
HTML are lacking a few things that they
should have let me okay so it does print
out this array so I do have it here and
should I fix yeah I should really should
fix my HTML there let's let's just
search for basic HTML page I don't know
what this blog is nope
how about MDN mdn is good all right well
here's what I'm missing - oh I need this
so yeah these are the two tags I need so
just one second I'll put a doctype and
now let me put this made a tag okay so
good now it should stop complaining
sweet if i refresh this is just warning
me views in development mode but I
already know that because I imported the
development version of view so that's
what I wanted okay so now this array is
available on quotes so let's do
something with it let me go into data
and say quotes yeah quotes is quotes
basically can I use that shorthand in
the browser
maybe let's see I'm gonna check it out
so you also has these view J s dev tools
unfortunately in Firefox I can't to zoom
in even though I can zoom in on the
console here and every single other tab
I can't zoom in on the view dev tools
but I'm gonna try oh no that doesn't
work
okay well I'll fix
I'll fix su Ming figure out something to
zoom in by next time anyway so I can see
in view in these view dev tools that
shows me what data I have inside my view
instance what Dad I have available so
it's showing me I have this quotes array
so that's a good way where the V dev
tools is really useful to check and kind
of debug and kind of look around your
data and methods and stuff okay so I
have quotes available now so what do I
want to do I want to select a quote and
display it here so I'm going to just
create I'm going to say quote is or let
me call it current quote the one I'm
gonna display on the screen so current
quote is quotes and then at index 0 oh
yeah and then I need to display this on
the screen so now that I have current
quote available as a variable inside my
template I'm gonna get rid of this
boilerplate and use the double curly
brace syntax and put current quote there
and let me see sweet
we don't make mistakes just happy little
accidents famous famous Bob Ross quote
let me put quotes on the outside of that
make it more quote like oh wait okay
sweet I like it it's not random cuz it's
just taking the first one in the array
but still a step forward okay so now oh
yeah
I'll need to put the author or the quote
say er here the person who said that
whatever it's called so um but let me do
that in a second let me first took up
this button new quote that's the fun
part so now in my view instance I can
also have methods have a object of
methods so basically functions that I
can use inside my view in my template
here or in this case my HTML so let me
just create a new quote method here and
so it'll be a function called new quote
I don't need to pass any arguments into
this function so I won't define any
parameters and I'm going to be updating
current quote though so I can access
anything on this view instance it's just
an object so I can access it with this
okay so actually sorry I have this
backwards I was looking at it I was like
me and my something wrong with this
syntax okay so the key has to be the
name which is new quote and then
actually I'm going to make this in arrow
function oh no wait I think because the
view instance does some stuff I can just
make this a regular function we'll see
how this works okay so I'm gonna be
updating current quote here and I can
mutate State the what's in data here is
called the component state so I can
mutate that just by accessing current
quote off of the this object and setting
it equal to whatever I want but I want a
random quote so I'm going to need to
find choose a random number and then
access that random quote in the array so
I'm actually going to look this up so
generate random number in JavaScript oh
yeah sorry I didn't see that Bruce
doctype yeah isn't that what I have I
think that's what I copied off of mdn
yeah it is okay
so random number how to generate random
numbers in JavaScript math dot random
get random integer so math dot random so
math dot random generates let me zoom in
here so math dot random generates a
random number between 0 and 1 and then
you can times that so I think if I times
that by the max number that I want and
then floor it because I don't have a
minimum my minimum is just 0 so let me
give this a shot and figure it out so I
have the math object because that's just
available in JavaScript so I can do math
dot random and then I'll do times the
max number that I want so
that will be let's see between or the
max number is the length of the quotes
array so I'll do quotes dot length and
actually quotes dot length minus 1
because it's 0 indexed okay so I'll wrap
this in parentheses and then I think
let me just console dot log this
somewhere else real quick so I can
figure it out okay so let me get rid of
that and let's see what that is
okay yeah so it's two point eight nine
seven whatever if i refresh its another
random number so what I'm going to do to
make this random or to make it an
integer I'll do math dot floor and then
wrap it so Matt thought floor just
rounds down since I have a number with
decimals now it'll become an integer by
rounding cool so I got two zero three
three two zero
there's no four well I ever get four I'm
not sure let me get rid of this minus
one
or maybe it just doesn't like force its
it keeps I don't know if you can see
it's like 0 1 1 1 2 4 yes 4 okay alright
so your breaks later we'll fix it
alright so let me copy that and paste it
here get rid of this line okay so I'm
gonna say number equals that whole thing
that we just did math dot floor math dot
random quotes that length oh I don't
need the parentheses around that anymore
cuz I'm not - in one all right I mean
check the comments do you need to floor
the whole thing yes because if I didn't
so if I just floored this math dot
random then it would come out as zero
every time and then when I multiply
quotes dot length it would always be
zero so I wouldn't be getting a random
number anymore so I have to floor after
I multiply basically okay so now I have
this random number from should be from
zero to four we're hoping let's see
current quote okay and now we need to
get a random quote out of the quotes
array so we can pass in that random
index or we can access it via a random
index and then set current quote to that
quote and let's see if this works it's
not changing something's wrong
what's going on we don't make mistakes
just having little accidents so we're
setting current quote it
quotes and the number okay oh you know
what we're not doing we're never calling
this function Wow okay we're never
calling this function so we're setting
the first quote as the 0th index but
we're never calling the function no
quote or new quote so we have to hook up
this button to man to actually call the
function okay let's see and okay so new
quote and so here view J s lets us hook
up methods using the at click so this is
actually shorthand for V dash on and
then V dash on needs to be followed by
an event you'll see this pattern a lot
in view these directives that gives you
V dash something like V model or what
else there's a bunch of oh yeah before
for looping the if or conditionals so V
on and then I'll say on click when
someone clicks this button I am gonna
run a function which I put the name of
the function inside of the quotes the
name of the function is new quote so I'm
gonna put a new quote in there and
basically V dash on can just be written
as an @ sign so that's what I always use
anyway so at click meaning now view is
watching for this click event and going
to run this function when that click
event occurs so let me refresh in the
browser click sweet it's changing do you
see that okay awesome so now we're
getting random quotes so this is
actually or this actually fits the
requirement
I think generate random quotes but
there's some more things that we're
gonna do with this
so no new chat messages so I guess
everyone's following along okay let me
just check one second this is set up a
little bit different differently than my
regular live streams so I'm just making
sure I'm not missing anything all right
so let's see generate new quotes let me
look at my mock-up yeah so I can style
this a little bit more like I have I
mean all these quotes are Bob Ross so I
don't need I can just hard code the
author here and then the new quote
button I'll style that a little bit so
here I don't like this right at the box
or the card so I'm going to Center the
button and add a margin top so let's see
this button I can add a class to the
button let's say I'm adding a class of
margin top two which is that something
like eight pixels okay that's good and
now if I do let me see if this works so
margin I assumed in again so wait okay
so let me add a margin Y so on the y
axis of auto so that should be margin
left and margin right of auto and no
that doesn't work at all wait what I
really want is the x axis right yeah the
x axis okay that didn't work so I'm
gonna try flexbox then
all right so I'll leave the margin top
there and I'm gonna zoom out one I think
this is good that was too close
okay so I had the card and this column
here I'm gonna set this as flex I think
no wait wait I think there's something
else I can do so I have this column
that's wrapping the button too but I
could put the button in its own row let
me try that so let me try putting a new
row here so div class equals row and
then close that alright so and now
inside of that row I need to make a
column so it's gonna have the same
layout as this card so I'll make a
column let me just leave it at column
for right now okay
now close that div and now okay and now
I pasted the button in here and let me
see how this looks not very good so I
need the same column offsets and stuff
that I have above so I'll do column
small 6 and then offset small of 3 all
right and apparently I still need the
margin top because it's not giving me
extra margin I thought it was gonna give
me that but it seems like I need the
margin top still all right so for the
button um maybe I'll just create a block
button so it'll go no that's not going
to look good I need to Center this
button so here I'm gonna say display
flex and then justify
[Music]
justify content center but let me see
let me look at bootstrap and make sure I
have that correct so let me look at
their flex utilities which are basically
a bunch of flex box classes so you don't
have to go and create your own CSS it
gives you these classes to implement
flex box and I'm gonna look at justify
because that's horizontal in this case
so I can do justify Content Center so
let me try that class justify content
Center okay sweet and now I have my
quote button in the middle awesome
thanks all right
so cool
this actually is pretty good it's not
too bad okay let me add Bob Ross here
because I need to I don't know
cite cite him yeah cite him because he
was the one who said the quote okay so I
think here I could do I mean bootstrap
has their own like block quote styles
but since I'm inside of a card I don't
think I want those here I just want like
regular oops Bob Ross yeah I just want
regular paragraph tags and okay that's
pretty good
alright I like that for now
okay of course with view and since this
is a view stream I'm trying to focus on
view this is really simple in fact this
is almost nothing but I could still put
this in another file to kind of clean it
up so let me create a new javascript
file to put my view inside so I'll
create a new file and call it can't call
it for you let's call it I don't know
main dot J yes and now I'm going to wait
copy everything out of and everything
out of my script tag here so get rid of
that paste it here and okay so now I
have this view instance in a separate
file so if I import that file in a
script tag let's see source equals main
dot J s and close the script tag oh wait
there so this should work the same way
yep cool all right so now I can yeah
basically do whatever I want in here now
one of the things about view is that I
can also like I don't have to write all
of this HTML inside of the HTML here I
can insert it I get so I can insert the
HTML through view by creating something
called view components of U dot
component and then defining a component
here and where it will
inside of you so I don't know uh I
figured I might as well do that since
I'm not starting the next project until
next Friday so let me take let's let's
take this card actually so let me take
the card I'm gonna call this quote card
and you're gonna see why it's called
quote card or the importance of calling
it quote card in a second so I'm
defining a view component and yeah let's
see I think I can take where does it
start
I think it's start
yeah it starts here so I could take this
section and put it inside of a template
here so I'm just using back ticks so I
can oh wait wait wait
undo undo there we go
so it will so I can do it on multiple
lines and save the formatting okay I
will have to change this though a little
bit but now the thing about quote card
is I can now reference it because it's a
component I can reference it as if it
was an HTML tag kind of so I can say
quote card and let me I don't like the
highlighting for that let me make that
all one word so let me say quote card
and then close it so quote card see what
happens there
yeah so the quote card is displaying you
can see because it still has the card
there but it's not
I guess the it's not seeing the variable
because this is over here on the data
and methods over here so what I could do
is add these data and methods over to
the component I could add let's see
after template I could add a data object
and then I could add methods also if I
wanted to and move these over to this
component so each component would kind
of take care of the piece of the page
that it's supposed to be at like I could
have one component for this I could have
another component for a nav menu and one
for the sidebar but this is such a
simple thing I just wanted to show
components here but I'm gonna get rid of
this oops not that okay I'm gonna keep
that part and then undo that all right
does anyone have any questions about
view or anything you want to know about
view one thing we can do is actually add
transitions so because animations are so
common in web development view has some
animation features built into it which
is nice and I think that would add a
nice feature to this app as well let me
make sure yeah it's still working okay
let's see you let's go to a view and
look at animations and transitioning
yeah this is it okay so if you so when
we right now we click new cool
and there's really like no transition
animation but we could actually make the
quote animate in like fade in/fade out
fly-in fly-out stuff like that so let's
do a transition animation for the quote
so let's see omitting prefix CSS rule
okay
so they're toggling this okay so they're
toggling this element basically
conditionally conditionally showing this
element with a V if and when it appears
it I believe they're setting okay
they're setting some kind of bounce in
so okay so it leaves to the right and
comes from the right it fades in and
fades out oh that one's really extreme
all right so I'm going to add a basic
animation here let's see so basically
whatever I want to animate in and out I
can use a transition between it so let
me try to do this for the quotes and see
I mean this is just showing and hiding
show/hide based off of a boolean so let
me see how this is gonna work for the
quotes because I don't know so let's see
transition name slide fade
let me wrap the actually it would be
this I guess I would be wrapping by the
way this transition tag and the template
tags transition tags that you see in
view they don't render to the
they're just there for functionality so
they don't add any kind of overhead or
and you can't see them in the Dom after
it's just an easy way to add certain
things alright so let's try to animate
this transition oops okay this is kind
of interesting because I'm so used to
using the view CLI and you know I just
go in there and generate a new view
application so it's interesting you know
going back to HTML and really starting
from scratch with you this is kind of
fun okay so now I'm wrapping actually
this I want to move here yeah so now I'm
just wrapping the current quote hmm I
wonder if I want it directly around my
what's coming in and out the quote
instead of the P tag I'm not sure let's
see so now I need CSS styles so what
this transition is doing is giving me a
bunch of classes that I can style in CSS
and make these transitions so let's see
this is a slide fade that's fine it's
easier to see so I'm gonna copy their
styles here because they're basically
using you know default CSS properties
and you can see that because the
transition is slide fade view gives you
the class slide fade interactive when
it's leaving the screen leave active and
enter and leave to the States for those
okay so now I need some CSS so let me
add I guess I'll just I'll tag here so
let me add a style tag
style and alright no highlighting at all
that's fine alright so now I should have
all of these classes active on the dom
and let me see what the transition is
looks like no there's definitely no
transition so I think this would work
let me try something so if I had a
conditional element let me do what it
said in the doc so let's make P tag here
and this would be if show and I'm gonna
make this variable in a second so oh
wait it's V if so it's a the V if
directive the conditional directive and
view and then if show I'm gonna say
hello close the P tag okay and now in my
view instance let me create a boolean
called show so I have access to that in
my HTML so now I have show and let's say
false and since V if since this is this
show variables false it shouldn't show
up right now yeah it doesn't show up and
now if I set it to true it should be
there okay good so now let me set it
back to false and since I already have
this button and method I'm gonna add
that extra here so I'm gonna say this
dot show I'm gonna toggle it so this dot
show equals the opposite of what it
currently is so if it's true it's gonna
be full so if it's false it's gonna be
true okay so alright so it does anim in
and out cool
so that's working but how do I do that
when it's when the new quote is coming
in so actually my opinion view or react
so I did use react for I don't know
several years at least and I do I still
use it a little bit for work but I mean
I just so there are some things that I
like a lot better about view and why I
prefer view and I don't want to say
anything bad about react in fact
learning react really helped me
career-wise to get a job and to work on
lots of different cool projects view I
think is a bit I guess easier to use in
in that they have a lot of conventions
that where they implement them using
this human first approach so even their
naming conventions this is a simple
example so let's look at lifecycle hooks
in view so they have these lifecycle
hooks let me see if they list them all
at the top nope nope okay where are we
in their API
alright so lifecycle hooks they have
created when the components created
before create before mount mounted when
you compare this to some other
frameworks like let's say react you have
on I can't even remember every time I
try to remember them I have to think
about it but with view it's like just
one word it's exactly what it does
mounted okay that means it's past tense
and mounted before update means before
it happened and then updated so after
the component updated and you
these lifecycle hooks why can't I
remember the react ones right now I was
just using them yesterday anyway so it's
much they made it much simpler from the
naming to the documentation to how to
start a view project I have to eject
view the vo team like preaching to you
right now so the view team made a really
smart decision
so back in 2015 and 2014 whenever I
started react it was really hard to
create a react project I I became a web
pack expert I learned web pack I learned
babble I learned react and redux all of
those different pieces view chose to
make it simpler and make all of these
different packages under the core of the
view umbrella so the view core team has
its own state management so view X their
own router view router they have their
own the create view create which is kind
of like create react up view has it
built in to the views they have their
own view CLI so it's just I think the
ecosystem is much easier to work with
then react and I like some of their
design decisions now bear in mind view
had the benefit of coming after angular
and after react so even they admit that
they took a lot of things from angular
and react and tried to improve upon them
so it's not like view just made up
everything on its own
no it learned from other frameworks so
yeah anyways I really like view I think
it's a breath of fresh air in the wild
world of front-end JavaScript where
there's so much going on all the time
and views just really nice to use I
guess
okay anyway so I have this transition so
I think I'm not sure so what I would
normally do so if I built a regular
application here I would I would
basically be going to a route like
quotes and then slash the quote ID and
when you do that view routing when it
routes to the new route you can make a
transition like this but honestly I
don't know how to do it without routing
and without you know showing and hiding
so this would be an interesting thing to
figure out maybe how to animate the
quotes as they change I guess
as state updates oh wait so we did talk
about lifecycle hooks so we could do a
lifecycle hook like updated and this is
a function oh wait this needs a comma so
we have this updated life cycle hook so
every time the component updates which
it updates every time we call this new
quote function because it's doing or
updating the current quote let me get
rid of this show stuff that was just
temporary okay so it updates the current
quote and so this will call the update
function every single time so I can
console dot log let's see I'll just say
updated and we can see this in the
terminal by the way I'm not saying don't
use react because we actually teach
react at our coding school because there
are so many jobs in react so I'm not
trying to say it's bad or in
thing okay I have an error here show
yeah so basically don't miss misquote me
there all right just because I prefer
view doesn't mean that other people
shouldn't use react okay
um yeah this is good oh yeah I was like
why isn't it showing up so I have to hit
new quote and you can see it calls the
updated function every time my face is
in the way alright so it calls this
updated function down here every time
okay so because I was thinking maybe
this some way in the updated function to
call an animation what you could do here
is set new classes animation classes so
this is this would be interesting so
here I could put a variable hmm I could
say you know I
I don't know so here I would have to put
in animating and then animated variable
so I would have to do a set timeout I
think I don't know is that something you
guys want to see a animation I basically
finished a little bit early on this I
thought this was going to take a longer
period of time to make the quote machine
so I'm gonna try to make it a little bit
better so yeah let me try to make this
updated life cycle hook work and I'll do
let's see updated
how am I gonna do this yeah I'm gonna
have to use a set timeout to add the
class and then remove the class when
that's over so before the class I'm
gonna let me say animating it's true
okay so I have this animating boolean
right now and I'm gonna set this dot
animating equals true oh no this should
be false by default cuz it's not always
animating but when it is animating
whenever updates this the animating is
true and then let's see and then set
timeout needs a function so I'll pass it
a function and then at the end here I'll
say after one second run the function
and this function will say this
animating equals false ok and now this
CSS this dot animating needs to be
hooked up to a CSS to CSS somehow so I'm
gonna do that inside my HTML I'm gonna
get rid of transition and here inside
the paragraph tag I'm gonna put a CSS
class but I'm going to bind this class
to a variable so I'm going to instead of
just a string here I'm going to actually
do V bind and that sets it up to where I
can use view syntax inside of my air
inside of the class to
so I'm actually going to bind that
boolean so that animating animating
boolean I'm basically gonna say if this
animating boolean is true then I'm going
to add this class called animate ok and
now this animate class I think I'm just
gonna copy what they did here I'm not
that great with CSS animations but let's
see what would I need I'm not gonna do a
leave animation right now so let me get
rid of that and let's do the animate
class here so basically what would it do
it would move ten pixels in and set ok
the opacity would be zero hmm and then
it would ease in over 0.3 seconds let me
change this to 0.5 or 0.8 yeah so we can
see it
let's see animate all right property or
method animate is not defined on the
instance prints during render I think
what I need to do here is actually put
this inside of a string okay okay it
seems to like that alright so when I
click new quote I don't see anything but
let me look inside of here so it has the
class animating
okay so I think what I'm doing is let me
look at class class and style bindings
yeah there's a couple different syntaxes
you can use this array syntax and object
syntax so what i'm doing here is doing v
bind class equals active is active text
Jean oh I got them backwards that's what
I did so let me do this
animate oh I guess you just need quotes
if you have - in there so I can do
animate and then this should be
animating okay so it sets the animate
class or it it will have the animate
class if animating is true okay so this
should work let's see um wait let me
inspect this alright so right now
there's no class and if I change it okay
and it has an animate class and it still
has an animate class all right well it's
getting closer anyway let me see I'm
gonna check the chat just wondering if
this webinar will be made available
after it yeah so this should be up on
YouTube in perpetuity this is just a
regular YouTube video I just happen to
be live and you're seeing me probably
five seconds after I speak every time
yeah so this will be always on YouTube
and next time actually we'll be using
the view CLI to create this this is more
of a basic
action so I wanted to kind of step
through getting more and more advanced
with UJS as we create more projects I
see okay so I'm gonna just finish up
this animation and then yeah and then
I'll be updating the github repo after
this so I have animate which is bound to
the animating class or the animating
boolean and let's see so time out this
dot animating is false I can see this in
my view dev tools actually maybe that
would be the better thing so let me go
into my V dev tools and I'm gonna
refresh real quick alright so here if
you can see it says animating is false
now when I click new quote this is
animating is true and oh okay I think
what it's doing is it's not it's not
waiting for this to finish in the update
function basically so maybe I'll just
make in intro animation and let me see
so oh wait this isn't proper syntax so
maybe that's why it's not working okay
let me refresh it one more time
[Music]
refresh some reason it's not wanting to
refresh okay yeah I'm not sure what
happened why it locked up there
huh I don't know I guess my browser's
mad right now
alright so
let me check one thing real quick let me
see waiting for that to go and I'll say
coat or quote machine code from
livestream and now I'm gonna push it to
the github repo okay so that worked I'm
not sure why my random quote machine
isn't coming up anymore but now when i
refresh my github repo the browser is
not happy I'm gonna actually gonna try
to open a different browser let me try a
chromium browser right now let me try
brave all right
let's see if it loads cool so that's
loading oh good so we have that
animation which only leaves the screen
and never comes back sweet
oh right because we're animating from
what do we do we're all we're animating
from visible to invisible basically
because we have opacity zero so it's
going from opacity of one where you can
see the word to opacity of zero where
you can't see it at all okay so I think
what I want to do is actually replace
the opacity instead of zero I want it to
be visible and that's the animate class
so before the animate class is there
before it's there let me card text card
text P so let me add a class or just
styles based off of the card text P and
I'm gonna say Oh past city weight
that'll that'll access both of these P
or paragraph tags though let's see okay
chrome is locked up right now not Chrome
Firefox so let's see let me look at CSS
first child so the first child selector
okay I can do colon first child so in
card text I'm going to try that so I
only want to affect this first paragraph
so I'm going to do first child and then
set the opacity
as zero here okay let's see if that
works
oh wait go back to brave okay opacity is
zero no well the quotes are changing but
you can't see any of them under yeah
they're not okay so opacity is 0 and
then the animate class hmm is opacity of
one so I wonder if it's just because of
specificity CSS let me add an important
statement here okay I feel like there's
gonna be so many things after this dream
that I want to fix
okay that's still not working
hmm so let me see so I had let me just
transition something else not the
opacity let me say color is red here all
right okay cool it transitioned into
color red
all right it would be kind of
interesting to also do
I guess random colors with the random
text so they all changed yeah so does
anyone oh it's locked up too all right
so a couple things the code is available
on github so if you go let me pull it up
in brave so if you go to my github
account you can see all of the code and
actually all of the free code camp
projects are gonna be here this is just
the first one done in bouge s
and feel free to raise an issue to open
an issue if you have any anything to add
to this repo or even if you just want to
practice contributing to open source
this is a good place to do it if you
have any questions about view then you
can post them in the comments below and
you can also check out my channel
Faraday Academy I do lots of view
content on there and feel free to reach
out to me all right thanks so much for
the live stream in the next live stream
we're gonna be working on the next free
code camp project which is a little bit
more in-depth so I think it's gonna take
maybe the full two hours because we're
planning on doing from 10:00 a.m. to
noon so it should be or that's on my
time zone anyway it's probably different
for you because I'm on Eastern Daylight
Time right now so it should be a
two-hour live stream next time we're
gonna add in some more features do view
from the command line and a few other
things so yeah thanks for thanks for
tuning in and have a great day everyone